all right we've just done our next big
interview with uh former private wealth
lawyer and tax expert steph robbie
that's gonna hopefully be up next week
but for now check out this highlight
from our last big interview
on the systemic issue you made a really
good
uh point earlier when we were chatting
about
how covert has accelerated a lot of this
stuff you may have said this before yeah
but i thought it was just really
a really good illustration of
yeah so
we've covered this on the channel but
we'll go through it again which is like
why covert has increased in quality so
badly right which is
economically what kobe was was basically
banning rich people from spending money
that is what economically what it did
because if you're an ordinary person or
a poorer person the vast majority of
your expenditures are on rent food
mortgage bills and you still have to pay
all those things in coving so your
expenditures don't really go down that
much you maybe you can't go to the pub
you save a little bit but if you're a
very wealthy person your expenditures
are largely on luxuries
you know expensive holidays or expensive
you know meals
lots of expensive things that all got
banned
so what that meant was during kovid
we basically banned the spending of the
rich
now
in normal times there's a sort of
circular flow of money which is when
ordinary people pay their mortgage or
they rent it goes to rich people but
rich people have very high incomes and
they spend a lot of money which drives
the wages of ordinary people but if you
stop rich people spending money
ordinary people still have to pay the
rent and they still have to pay the
mortgage so instead of money flowing
around in a circle it's just flowing
from ordinary families to the rich and
staying there
and then these guys have lost their
incomes
so what happens the government
substituted the incomes with printed
money and then from the perspective of
an ordinary person the situation seems
the same because you're getting an
income it's not from the rich anymore
it's from the government so you feel
you're unaffected but that money is then
flowing to the rich and just staying
there and just piling up and up and up
and up and up so from the very beginning
of kovis you could predict that
at the end of kovid
it's going to look like we're just
reopening the economy but we're not
we're reopening the economy with a
massive amount of cash in the bank
accounts of rich people and it's huge
right because the amount of money
printed was 450 billion pounds which is
10 000 pounds per adult but it all gets
accumulated by the rich so if that all
goes to the top ten percent we're
talking about a hundred thousand pounds
cash extra in the bank account of every
single rich person in the country
and then afterwards when inflation blows
up everybody's like how did that happen
it's like everyone's sort of confused
about it which is driving me mad and i
think sort of the big thing which i'm
trying to push at the moment on the
channel is to make people aware look
this is not some natural disaster this
has happened because we allowed the rich
to profit enormously from kovid they've
got way more money it's government
printed money that's pushing price up
and that's making your life harder and
the obvious way to deal with that is to
tax this enormous amount of money
they've made but for some reason
nobody's talking about this enormous
amount of money the rich have
more money than they've ever had before
enormously more money than they've ever
before and we have a crisis now which
seriously is going to mean ordinary
families can't feed their kids and heat
their homes
and yet the government is doing nothing
about tax on the rich in fact they're
raising taxes national insurance which
is a tax only on workers which excludes
the income of billionaires it's that's
crazy yeah it's crazy it drives me ahead
yeah
that's that's a great monologue by the
way
you should clip that and just put that
on his twitter that's brilliant